Nikolai has been an addict for ten years
like many Russians the 28 year old began
taking drugs at parties
first amphetamines than heroin now the
designer drug known as spice it's easy
to get hold of in Russia he orders it by
text message
ten minutes later he's told where he can
collect it his package has been left in
a hole in the wall scoring drugs here
isn't difficult before you had to meet
someone in person the deal would happen
face to face that was dangerous you
could be caught by police it's much
easier today Dmitry bought off is all
too familiar with stories like this he
was an addict for 11 years now he works
at the city without drugs foundation in
Yekaterinburg this video advertises
spice cheap ingredients from China have
flooded the Russian market and now
thanks to the Internet the drug is
available around the clock this is an
online shop selling drugs one of many
they buy the drug in large quantities
and then stash small packets of it
around the city but where purchasers can
then collect them Schama shop is a play
on the word shaman spice is cheap
compared to heroin or cocaine and you
can buy it at the click of a mouse
illegal businesses like these are
conducted through the darknet the hidden
corners of the web dimitri and his
colleague will report the site to the
authorities other anti-drug activists
focus on hunting down dealers groups
have been set up in most Russian cities
that help
by smoking out dealers bases they
believe the police are failing to
address the problem by themselves they
name and shame dealers by posting videos
of them online a briefing at the
foundation everyone present is a former
addict including the boss Andre
Cavanaugh heroin use has gone down in
Yekaterinburg but designer drugs are on
the rise and its addicts are dangerously
young drug addicts used to be between 23
and 25 now they're often between 14 and
15 there are some nine and even six year
old kids taking drugs an addict for 11
years Cavanaugh is proud he kicked the
habit
addiction is not an incurable disease he
says but a weakness to be conquered
around the world medication is used to
help people take their drug habit but we
do it without any tablets we're just
both quicker and easier
cold turkey
that's how Roman overcame his 13-year
addiction now he helps other addicts get
clean in the forests of Yekaterinburg
here they must be entirely
self-sufficient they have to survive
without any help
Roman takes us along to see for
ourselves
his job is to ensure that the recovering
addicts follow a strict daily routine
everyone has to do their bit it's like
living in a collective physical work is
good for people rehabilitation of
shouldn't be easy but it shouldn't be
too hard either
Arseniy has made it through the first
six months he misses city life and his
wife and three children but then he'd
rather spend one year without them than
the rest of his life when you get there
you just want to leave you want to get
away as quickly as possible by whatever
means then after a while when your body
starts to cleanse itself you realize
that you haven't lost everything in life
his drug abuse began at parties in st.
Petersburg it started with recreational
drugs than harder ones
I had problems at home my first wife
left me
Roman tells him to get a move on he
wants lunch served on time but then our
Sandi discovers a secret stash a new
arrival has hidden some eggs 18 eggs now
I know where all the eggs have got -
were you planning to sell them
embarrassed the boy brings them out he
wanted to use the money to buy something
to smoke Roman goes easy on him possibly
because we're filming lunch is ready
the ex-addicts have to prepare this
themselves Roman makes sure everything
is done properly
no one is given preferential treatment
that can lead to upsets
we all have different opinions but what
brings us together is our addiction you
talk about it a lot and that really
helps he hopes to be able to sell some
camera equipment in st. Petersburg in
about six months
Roman is optimistic about our Sandy's
future he's understood how essential it
is to make changes in his life there are
cameras in every room
Roman leaves nothing to chance right now
he lives a bit like an Orthodox priest
but at some point he wants to get back
to his old life again
he was once a shoemaker many in the West
say cold turkey is too hard for
recovering addicts but he says you can
only fight drugs by being tough Nicolae
however can't see any need to stop
taking drugs so far he's managed to keep
his addiction secret from his employer
he has enough drugs for the next few
days they've been a part of his life for
a long time
even when I just consider the last year
more and more young people are taking
drugs mainly because it's now so easy to
get a hold of them the chances of
getting caught are much lower here are
powerless to stop the spread of drugs
there are endless places to stash them
in Russia's major cities